[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: By now, you
probably understand
that Google customizes a lot
of our data center design.
This customization traces back
to the beginning of a data
center story, where it lives.
So how do we select
our data center sites?
Data center site
selection is all about
balancing a variety of factors.
A data center location has
to have the right combination
of energy infrastructure,
proximity to our users,
available workforce,
and available land.
Some of our data
center campuses are
the size of hundreds of
American football fields.
Yeah, that's a
lot of touchdowns.
One of the first
things to assess
is exposure to
natural disasters.
Areas that are prone to
earthquakes, extreme weather
events, or floods
aren't good candidates
to house thousands of machines.
Though sometimes it's
unavoidable for what
we're looking for,
so we accommodate
through our designs.
In case unexpected
scenarios arise,
we've designed for redundant
power supplies and data
replication.
Fiber network connectivity
is another factor.
Understanding latency
limits and distance
to nearby points of presence,
or network access points,
is a major piece of the puzzle.
And since power is
a high ongoing cost
and impacts the
environment, we always
search for reliable and
efficient carbon-free energy
options to ensure sustainable
operations around the clock.
Areas with temperate climates,
or other suitable environments,
provide options for 100%
outdoor air or water
cooling to augment or replace
mechanical air conditioning.
And add a cherry on top?
Finding sites with unique
geographic qualities
can improve environmental
performance.
For example, our data
center in Belgium
uses recycled water from
a nearby industrial canal
to cool its servers,
making it more sustainable
and the first Google
data center to eliminate
refrigerated cooling.
In Finland, we transformed an
old paper mill, located next
to the Bay of Finland,
into a data center.
The bay's water,
sitting at 57 degrees
Fahrenheit or 14 degrees
Celsius all year round,
allows us to use seawater
to cool the data center.
Our Taiwan data center
is one of Asia's most
efficient and
environmentally-friendly.
Our nighttime cooling and
thermal energy storage system
cools water at night when
temperatures are lower,
storing it in large,
insulated tanks.
Then during the day, it's
pumped throughout the facility
to cool our servers.
Thanks in part to a partnership
with Dutch farmer cooperatives,
our data center in the
Netherlands sources carbon-free
power directly from
local wind farms.
Our data center in Ireland uses
an advanced air cooling system
that takes advantage of
Ireland's temperate weather
to keep our servers
running smoothly.
As a result, the
data center can be
cooled efficiently
with outdoor air,
instead of air
conditioning units.
As you can see, there's no
one-size-fits-all for Google
data centers.
Each one is built to adapt to
local strengths and thrive.
But what does this
mean for you at home
and our real-world applications?
Find out next time on
"Discovering Data Centers."